now we're gonna talk about a new charity
which is calling on former servicemen to
come forward and act as mentors for
other veterans who find themselves in
prison after returning to civilian life
now having performed with thousands of
servicemen over the years we've got Jim
Davidson here he's the chairman of
what's called character combat and
alongside Jim is trustee for the charity
and Falklands War veteran Simon Weston
very good to see his guys now with in
care after combat Jim you've got this
project called Phoenix yeah right so
Phoenix arises from the ashes yeah what
is this project Phoenix with project
finish is very simply to find out and
ascertain exactly how many veterans
we've got in the criminal justice system
in prison to get in there with those
veterans sign them up to a project which
will enable us to stop them reoffending
what we try and do find them give them a
mentor someone of their own sort of you
know age someone that was in the
military talk to them find out what they
want to do and try and make that pathway
for them I mean it makes sense it's for
people that are in prison everyone in
prison not to offend when they come out
we think we can do that with the
veterans full big task of what it is yet
I mean yeah what sort of back in have
you got with this one well unfortunately
we've got Mike painting from the
government we've been working with the
government for quite a while on it
and it started way way before the
election and Mike painting has been a
big support he works in the Ministry of
Justice so he's being given us a huge
amount of support and advice and we're
really looking with the governor's from
the prisons that we're working with at
the moment to sort of really roll out
the program from there and then once
we've rolled out the program from those
specific prisons and we've got a success
rate then we are roll in to all the
others and as Jim can tell you the the
prisons in Wales they've basically asked
us to come in and do all of their
prisons it's very difficult to tell it
we think between about four and six
percent of the prison population if you
think there's 80,000 but they are the
biggest cohort group within the criminal
justice you know why that is Jim
well we'll find out Amon Simon did the
best little quote when we put the
brochure together about being a noble
warrior well you don't just be a you
don't live your life as a noble warrior
and then all of a sudden come out and
become a criminal that deserves a
custodial sentence yeah and it takes
quite a bit in this country now to get a
custodial sentence as we already know so
what's gone wrong something's gone wrong
and one of the things I remember
listening to an interview with Sugar Ray
Leonard and the rest of the interview
was great but he said something that's
very powerful and and the interview was
said to him what's the most difficult
thing you've found since retiring from
boxing and he said to remain relevant
yeah and I think a huge thing with these
guys you know the me sergeants corporals
you know color sergeants company
sergeant majors officers and all of a
suddenly they lose their relevancy with
society you're defined by what you do
all of them when people lose their job
and indeed then I've already lost a job
had lost a way of life but let me ask
you my friend good do they come out
under they all become cat burglars or
you know what what was certainly this
reynad would help that the thing we
found jackie was is really interesting
is that they they really don't want to
be there they want to come out and they
want another go they know they've made a
mistake and the overriding thing that
our team have to actually go in the
prisons is that all of them say if you
meet any other soldiers or you're
speaking to regiments a guy actually
said this to goosed one of our trustees
tell them we're sorry we let the side
down that gives you hope so they want to
be owned again they want to be valued
again they need their self-worth back
but this is where you need and part of
what you're doing is appealing for these
mentors yes yeah okay now so who are we
talking about what stage of veteran are
we talking about I mean do you have to
be xxxx forces yes you have to be x
forces because that's the best way you
can link with the same language so yeah
any age in it and and any combat really
I mean I've just been approached by one
young fellow we've yet a contact back
who's lost both his legs from
Afghanistan he wants to help mentor guys
who've been in prison so he can see the
value of it and he can see the need for
these guys to feel relevant again if
people watching this morning is saying I
could do that or I know somebody who
could highly they get in touch with you
I think I think the best thing is to is
to get on there our website just look up
care after combat it's WW care after
combat or garden I always get it wrong
Google or Google it Google care after
combat get on Twitter or you couldn't
call us on three hundred three four
three two five zero zero that's also our
emergency 24-hour line should anybody
have any grief and we come out like
International Rescue and sort them out I
wasn't heard them from this should do a
bit more when they're you know their
personnel leave to become civilian
bridging things I think I think they do
as much as they can and it has to be
said that ninety-nine point nine percent
of all the veterans in this country are
absolutely fine they're the ones you
want to employ they're the ones you want
on your team but a very few of them fall
through the cracks and no one can do
anything about that but we're going to
give them another chance we're not going
to say you get the specialized treatment
you do the crime you do your time what
we want to do is make sure they don't
know back in well fair play to you too
for doing what you're doing lovely
seeing you both good luck with it all
care after combat and the Phoenix
project but then that it's Jim Davidson
and Simon West and thank you both very
much
Hughie